K
TO THE BRINK OF NUCLEAR CRISES.
WILL RIPLEY, CNN, TAIPEI
TAIWAN.
>> AN EXPERT ON NUCLEAR
PROLIFERATION AND FORMER
PRESIDENT OF THE --
IT'S GOOD TO HAVE YOU WITH,
THIS IT HAS BEEN A WHILE.
>> THANK YOU, JOHN NICE TO BE
BACK.
>> IT SEEMS WE HAVE MOVED FROM
THIS IDEA OF USING NUCLEAR
WEAPONS AT A FIRST RATE
CAPACITY IS BEING UNTHINKABLE,
NOW IT'S BECOME SORT OF
ACCEPTABLE AT LEAST FOR SOME
COUNTRIES.
I WANT YOU TO LISTEN TO A
FORMER CIA ANALYST WITH AN
ASSESSMENT OF WHAT IS HAPPENING
IN PYONGYANG.
SPECIFICALLY REFERRING TO KIM
JONG-UN AND HIS SISTER, LISTEN
TO THIS.
>> IN ADDITION TO KIM JONG-UN'S
FOCUS ON TACTICAL NUCLEAR
WEAPONS, AND THESE MISSILE
TESTS.
WITH KIM JONG-UN AND KIM
YO-JONG BEEN THREATENING
PREEMPTIVE USE, TAKING A PAGE
OUT OF PUTIN'S PLAYBOOK.
>> WITH THAT IN, MIND A RECENT
SURVEY FOUND SUPPORTING SOUTH
KOREA FOR DEVELOPING ITS OWN
NUCLEAR WEAPONS, NOW JUST OVER
70%.
AND CALLS FROM TAIWAN TO HAVE
ITS OWN NUCLEAR DETERRENCE AS
WELL.
THIS LIST GOES ON.
FOUR BIG PICTURE FULL STOP.
HERE ARE THE DAYS OF LIVING
UNDER THE SECURITY OF AMERICA'S
NUCLEAR UMBRELLA COMING TO AN
END?
>> I WOULD NOT CALL IT OVER YET,
BUT IT IS DEFINITELY FRAYING AT
THE EDGES.
PART OF THAT IS BECAUSE OF WHAT
VLADIMIR PUTIN IS DOING.
HE IS TRYING TO NORMALIZE THE
USAGE OF TACTICAL NUCLEAR
WEAPONS.
TALKING ABOUT THIS AS A
REASONABLE STEP THAT HE MIGHT
TAKE IN A CONVENTIONAL WAR, TO
USE NUCLEAR WEAPONS FIRST.
NORTH GRIMMS DO NOT NEED ANY
LESSONS FROM THIS, FROM
VLADIMIR PUTIN OF COURSE.
THEY HAVE BEEN MAKING NUCLEAR
THREATS LIKE THIS FOR A LONG
TIME.
I AGREED WITH YOUR ANALYST,
THEY ARE SEEING A LITTLE BIT OF
A DIFFERENCE IN USING THEM
FIRST.
SO NOT USING THEM IN RESPONSE
TO A U.S. NUCLEAR STRIKE, BUT
USING THEM FIRST TO TRY TO
INTIMIDATE SOUTH KOREA AND
NORTH KOREA.
AND AS YOU GET THESE CASCADES
OF LOOSE TALK OF NUKES, YOU DO
START TO GET GOVERNMENTS
SERIOUSLY THINKING ABOUT
BREAKING THEIR COMMITMENTS TO
THE UNITED STATES.
SOUTH KOREA'S PROMISE, IT WOULD
NOT DEVELOP NUCLEAR WEAPONS.
BUT YOU SEE THIS KIND OF RISING
SENTIMENT IN JAPAN, IN SOUTH
KOREA, IN TAIWAN.
SO YES, IT IS A SIGN THAT THE
GLOBAL REGIME THAT WE SET UP TO
STOP STATES FROM GETTING THESE
NUCLEAR WEAPONS IS WEAKENING.
IT IS FRAYING AT THE EDGES.
AND THERE IS A NEED OF URGENT
REPAIR.
>> REGARDING NORTH KOREA
SPECIFICALLY, JEFFREY LEWIS IS
AN ARMS CONTROL EXPERT,
TWEETING WHAT I FIND NOTABLE IS
THAT THESE LAUNCHES ARE NOT
FRAMED AS TESTS OF THE MISSILES
THEMSELVES, BUT RATHER OF THE
UNITS THAT LAUNCHED THEM.
SUGGESTING THESE SYSTEMS ARE
DEPLOYED.
SPECIFICALLY WHAT IS HE MEAN BY
THAT?
>> IT'S A KEY POINT.
YOU DO MILITARY TESTS FOR TWO
REASONS.
DEVELOPMENTAL, TO TEST THE
SYSTEM.
THEIR EXAMPLE, THE INTERMEDIATE
RANGE BALLISTIC MISSILE THAT
FLEW OVER JAPAN.
IT WAS A NEW CONFIGURATION OF A
MISSILE THAT THEY HAD.
THEY WERE TESTING, IT DOESN'T
WORK.
WHAT --
THERE WASN'T A DOWNED OR SERIES
OF TESTS.
MISSILE TESTS TOGETHER THAT
WERE USED IN WELL TESTED
MISSILES.
BUT THEY WEREN'T TESTING THE
DELIVERY VEHICLE.
THEY WERE TESTING THE ABILITY
OF THE UNITS TO HAVE A
COORDINATED EXECUTION OF A
STRIKE.
AND THEN THEY BRAGGED ABOUT.
SO YOU SAW NORTH KOREAN MEDIA
SAY THAT THIS WAS AN EXERCISE
OF TACTICAL NUCLEAR WEAPON
STRIKES.
THEY ARE SENDING A CLEAR
MESSAGE TO SOUTH KOREA, TO THE
UNITED STATES.
THAT WE ARE READY TO USE THIS
IF WE ARE PUSHED.
>> IF RUSSIA IS TO USE A
NUCLEAR WEAPON, MOST BELIEVE IT
WOULD BE A TACTICAL NUCLEAR
WEAPON.
UNDER THE TREATIES, MOSCOW IS
NOT REQUIRED TO MAKE PUBLIC AN
ALL STRATEGIC NUCLEAR WARHEADS.
THE FEDERATION OF AMERICAN
SCIENTISTS BELIEVE THE NUMBERS
JUST SHY OF 2000.
WHICH IS INCREDIBLE ANYTHING.
HOW EFFECTIVE ARE THESE WEAPONS
IN A PRACTICAL SENSE.
WHAT WOULD BE THE RESPONSE FROM
THE U.S. AND NATO IF MOSCOW DID
YOU SEE THIS KIND OF WEAPON.
>> RONALD REAGAN AND MCAL
GORBACHEV STARTED THIS DOWN THE
ROAD OF ELIMINATING THESE
WEAPONS.
THEY TRIED TO DO IT ALL AT ONCE,
THEY COULD NOT.
THEY STARTED STEADY REDUCTIONS
OVER THE LAST 30, 35 YEARS.
BUT THOSE REDACTIONS HAVE
STOPPED.
WE NEVER FINISHED THE JOB.
SO VLADIMIR PUTIN DOES HAVE
SOMEWHERE BETWEEN 1000, 2000
SO-CALLED TACTICAL WEAPONS.
WEAPONS THAT CAN BE FITTED TO
SHORT RANGE, MEDIUM-RANGE
SYSTEMS LIKELY ITS CANDOR
MISSILE.
THESE ARE NOT SMALL EVANS.
THESE ARE HIROSHIMA SIZE, TWO,
THREE, FIVE TIMES THE SIZE.
THESE ARE MAJOR WEAPONS OF MASS
DESTRUCTION.
SO THERE IS NOTHING TRIVIAL
ABOUT THEIR USE.
IT'S NOT LIKE YOU COULD USE
THIS THING AND IT WOULD BE LIKE
A CONVENTIONAL EXPLOSION.
NOW.
EVEN THE SMALLEST ONE OF THESE,
STILL MANY TIMES LARGER THAN
ANY CONVENTIONAL EXPLOSIVE
FORCE.
THIS IS SERIOUS, I THINK THE
PROBABILITY OF THEIR USES LOW.
BUT IT IS NOT ZERO.
AND THAT SHOULD WORRY ALL OF
US.
>> WHEN PUTIN HAS SAID HE WILL
DO SOMETHING, IN THE PAST HE
HAS DONE IT.
>> YES, HE HAS GOT SEVERAL
PURPOSES HERE, MAINLY A TERROR
TACTIC, MAINLY TRYING TO WEAKEN
EUROPEAN SUPPORT FOR UKRAINE,
SPLIT AMERICAN SUPPORT FOR
UKRAINE.
TRY TO CONVINCE THE UKRAINIANS
TO SURRENDER AND LET HIM OCCUPY
THE LAND THAT HE HAS OCCUPIED.
BUT BENEATH THAT IS ALSO THE
VERY REAL THREAT.
HE HAS THE MEANS TO DO IT.
HE HAS A METHOD.
RUSSIAN DOCTRINE CALLS FOR THE
FIRST USE OF NUCLEAR WEAPONS.
IF THEY ARE LOSING A
CONVENTIONAL WAR.
HE CERTAINLY HAS THE MOTIVE.
HE IS LOSING THIS WAR.
BOTH IN UKRAINE AND NOW IN
RUSSIA.
WHERE MORE MEN ARE LEAVING THE
COUNTRY AND THEN SURGING INTO
THE ARMED FORCES.
SO YES, THIS IS A REAL RISK, WE
HAVE TO TAKE IT SERIOUSLY, WE
HAVE TO DO ALL WE CAN TO
CONVINCE HIM THAT THIS IS A
LOSING MOVE.
THAT THIS WILL NOT WIN THE WAR
FOR HIM.
AND IF HE TAKES THIS MOVE.